you
our Series a more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us as Americans is
far greater than what divides us nearly
one year after Hurricane Harvey
devastated Houston Texas beyond his home
town many people are still unable to
return to their homes a small group of
military veterans and several dedicated
volunteers are helping to rebuild a
fourth largest city in this country one
home at a time chip Reid went to Houston
to meet them for Courtney column the
opportunity to help displaced Houston
residents return home has helped her
turn her own life around everything felt
that I was doing in life wasn't working
out after four years in the Coast Guard
and suffering from post-traumatic stress
disorders column found Team Rubicon a
Disaster Response organization made up
of military veterans and volunteers
helping to rebuild Houston I figured if
I'm miserable I might as well go help
other people but by helping other people
it pulled me out of that here is our
kitchen the house Courtney is
refurbishing belongs to the Postel
family who had to be evacuated by boat
when the storm hit all of a sudden my
daughter comes running up to us and she
says mom the bedrooms are flooding with
almost two feet of water inside the home
a terrorizing fear set in did you think
it was a lost cause this house at some
point at some point you say never once
have we been flooded and when the water
came in there was no stopping it living
outside the floodplain the pastels had
no flood insurance and lacked the funds
to rebuild on their own help from Team
Rubicon was a dream come true so now
when you come here you see this team of
volunteers from Team Rubicon how does
that make you feel
angel your angel when we thought that
there was no prayer no answer Team
Rubicon came in for Courtney this was
the payoff I had never had so many
people tell me how proud they were of me
and it is amazing from the air Houston
today looks dry and livable but nearly a
year after Harvey struck thousands of
residents are still waiting to return
home Team Rubicon saw that as an
opportunity I didn't see as much of a
response as I had wanted to see former
US Marine Elliot Rios says he felt
compelled to act after the relief
agencies and thousands of volunteers
left Houston in the months after the
storm we are feeling the need for a
group a community of individuals that
would have never been never gotten the
opportunity to go back into their home
Brian kal cono a former Army pilot flew
Blackhawk helicopters during two tours
in Iraq before finding Team Rubicon as a
way to continue to serve Brian what is
the most satisfying part of working for
Team Rubicon for you it doesn't matter
what your background it doesn't matter
what your past is you're here to help
and to be accepted into an organization
like that and have that unconditional
love is is you know it's very hard to
find this day and age I'm so happy to be
home for 67 year old Barbara Herndon who
spent 20 years in this home before being
forced to escape harvey's rising tides
oh my goodness that unconditional love
brought her back home on a recent steamy
afternoon I envisioned I was gonna cry
but I'm not crying thank you God you
don't want to cry no I don't need to cry
after moving Barbara in Team Rubicon
began work on another home the very next
day it's a cycle of veterans helping
others and at the same time helping
themselves thank you for all of the work
you're doing chip Reid CBS News Houston
and that's why we say Houston proud
great story